Hi, mystery recapped here. Today I'm going
to explain the horror thriller film called
30 Days Of Night . Spoilers ahead.
Watch out and take care
The movie starts with a filthy-looking man
dressed in a furry coat staring at a ship
harboring to the shore. It's wintertime
in Barrow, Alaska. Everyone in the town
is preparing for the upcoming polar night, a
month-long period where the sun doesn't rise.
It is the last day before 30 long days of
complete darkness begins. Barrow's sheriffs,
Eben Oleson, and Billy Kitka are examining a
pile of burnt satellite phones in the snow.
As a result, the town doesn't have access to
communication with the outside world. Most people
in the town are leaving to avoid the thirty days
of isolation while others are preparing for it.
At a local dog kennel, someone
gruesomely stabs all the dogs to death.
Eben gets informed about the situation and he
agrees to check it out. Eben’s wife Stella works
for Alaska's fire department. She is in the town
for the day but hasn’t told Eben because they
are not on good terms. However, on her way to
catch a flight home, she gets into an accident
so she calls Eben for help. However, Eben
replies that he is busy and sends Billy instead.
At the kennel, as Eben examines the dead dogs, he
notices that the dogs were stabbed repeatedly and
mutilated. He then reassures the owner
John Riis that they will find the culprit.
Meanwhile, Billy drives Stella to the airport
as fast as possible, but the flight has already
taken off, and the airport is closed. She is
now stuck in the town for the next 30 days too.
Eben goes to the police station,
where he meets his little brother
Jake Oleson and his grandmother, Helen Munson,
who works in the station as well. She informs
him about a vandalism problem at the Utilidor. As
Eben reaches Utilidor, he meets his friends Carter
and Wilson. He finds out that someone has
destroyed Wilson’s helicopter. Eben quickly
realizes that someone is trying to cut off every
means of communication with the outside world.
Elsewhere, the town’s electrical manager
Gus is busy working at his station when he
hears noises from outside. As he steps
outside to investigate with his torch,
he is surrounded by several mysterious figures. He
tries to run away but gets attacked. The strangers
slowly kill him while sucking his blood. It is
then revealed that the strangers are vampires,
who plan to feast on Barrow for the next 30 days!
The man from the beginning of the movie is in a
diner asking for raw meat and alcohol. When the
waitress denies his requests, he tries to attack
her. Eben and Stella are there too. As Eben tries
to stop the man, he gets progressively violent,
so he arrests him. Eben along with Stella then
take the man to the station and lock him up.
Elsewhere, three young refinery workers are
walking home from work. As they are on their
way home, a vampire suddenly drags one of them
into a dark alley. The other two don’t realize
what has happened. After a few seconds, the bloody
body of their friend is thrown in front of them.
The girl runs for her life while the
shocked man stares at his friend’s body.
As he does, we see the vampires behind him.
Back at the station, Eben is trying to interrogate
the strange man but he doesn't speak at all.
Suddenly, all the electronics in the station
stop working. Eben tries to call Gus but the
phone doesn't work either. The strange man in
the cell tells Eben to hide because ‘they’
are coming. However, Eben dismisses him.
Right after, the town’s electricity goes
off. Eben visits Gus’s office to inquire
about the electricity. When he reaches there,
he notices a trail of blood on the snow outside.
He then follows the trail to find Gus’s
head cut off from his body. He immediately
gets back to the people of the town and
warns them to stay inside their homes.
John and his wife Ally are indoors cooking dinner
when suddenly a vampire breaks in through the
kitchen’s glass window. The vampire then snatches
Ally and runs away. John tries his best to save
his wife and is injured in the process. In
the end, the vampire takes her away.
Back at the station, the man attacks
Jake. Eben comes in at the right time
and shoots his arm. Eben realizes that the
man knows something about Gus’s murderer,
but the man doesn’t reveal anything. After that,
Eben and Stella set off to look for the murderers
themselves. They notice something off in the way
and get out of their car. Stella sees something
through her binoculars and tells Eben to get
inside the car. As they drive away, a vampire
chases their car and gets on top of it.
Eben shoots the vampire but it doesn't affect him.
Stella somehow manages to drop him off the vehicle
and they escape. They then get a call from the
station. Helen screams for help on the other end.
They drive to the station to see blood splashed
everywhere. Jake and Helen are nowhere to be
found but the stranger is still inside the cell.
When asked what happened, he replies that they
don't want him and asks Eben to kill him.
Few people gather at the diner and they discuss
that the vampires don’t die when they get shot.
It is also revealed that they feed off blood. Then
we finally see the faces of vampires. Their leader
is named Marlow. He talks in a foreign language
and orders the others to kill everyone. Following
the orders, the vampires start killing everyone
who comes in their way. Eben and Stella rush to
the diner from earlier to investigate. Jake and
other survivors are there too. However, Helen was
killed by one of them. Eben takes everyone to
the attic of a house nearby. As the rest hide,
he and Stella go out to look for weapons.
But they are attacked by the vampires again.
They flip Eben’s car and try to drag Stella out.
Right when the vampires are about to kill Stella,
a bearded man named Brower comes to their aid
and hits the vampires with his bulldozer.
Eben and Stella somehow manage to get in Brower's
car and drive away. They drive back to the house
and meet the others in the attic. They hear
screams of people being killed outside but do
not dare to leave. Eben advises they can go to the
store to get something to eat after a few days.
They plan to stay in the attic for some time and
move to the utilidor when they get a chance.
Meanwhile, Marlow walks up to the stranger in the
cell and thanks him for completing ‘the task’.
He then snaps his head and kills him. Back in the
attic, they decide to sleep in shifts, ration out
their food, and plan their next step later.
For six days they remain hidden in the attic.
On the seventh day, they notice a girl outside
screaming for help. The girl is Jake's childhood
best friend. Eben realizes that it is a trap
when he sees the vampires on top of the roofs.
Still, he goes outside to save her
but can only watch her being tortured
and eventually killed by the vampires.
As he is about to return, someone calls his name,
and he notices John hiding in a corner. Eben
tries to help John, but he attacks him instead.
John has turned into a vampire because his
blood got infected when was trying to save
his wife. John tries to bite Eben. Knowing
that there is no other way to save John,
Eben chops his head off with an ax.
Eben then goes back to the attic and falls asleep
due to exhaustion. There, Wilson’s father, who
has dementia, tries to run away looking for his
dead wife. Wilson and Stella calm him down, but
the old man escapes through a window. When Wilson
finds out, he immediately runs outside to search
for him, despite Stella’s pleas to stay inside.
Eben wakes up from all the commotion.
Suddenly, a vampire comes inside the house
and Eben and Stella hide from him.
As the vampire is about to get them,
Wilson’s screams distract him. The vampire
finds Wilson outside the house and eventually
kills him. This gives Eben and Stella an
opportunity to go back into the attic.
Eighteen days pass in the attic. They have no food
left and everyone’s will to live is weakening.
They decide that on the very next hailstorm,
they will make a run for the store. Fortunately,
on the nineteenth day, a snowstorm struck.
They carefully walk towards the store.
When they reach there, they collect food
and supplies. Just then, they see a little
girl sucking the blood out of a dead body.
The little girl attacks Carter. Brower, Stella,
and Eben get her away from him and
Jake cuts the little girl’s head off.
The storm has already stopped when they are
about to leave. Now they are stranded in the
store. They decide to go to the utility in
the police station where they can be safe.
Stella says that the vampires cannot function
in sunlight that is why they have attacked
during the polar night. This reminds Jake of a UV
light that his grandmother used to grow plants.
Eben decides to run to his grandmother’s house to
distract the vampires and use the UV light to kill
them while others escape to the utility. He then
runs out screaming with an ax. The vampires hear
his screams and run after him. Others run to the
police station to hide in the utility room.
Elsewhere, Eben starts a generator in his
grandmother’s house. He then gets prepared
for the vampires with the UV light. The group
of vampires surround the house. Marlow orders
his girlfriend Iris, who is also a vampire, to
kill Eben. However, as Iris breaks through the
window inside the house, Eben shines the UV
ray on her face, burning it completely.
Eben then realizes the vampires are going to
turn the generator off. He makes his escape
from the back door. All the vampires go after
him but Marlow stays with a struggling Iris.
He then kills her to rid her of the pain.
All vampires go after him while Marlow stays
with Iris. Seeing Iris struggle to stay
alive, Marlow kills her himself.
Brower then tells Eben that it’s his turn to
distract them now. He gets into a bulldozer and
attacks the vampires chasing Eben. After a small
fight, he runs the bulldozer into a building and
gets all the vampires to come inside. He then
proceeds to light himself in an explosion.
Fortunately, Eben reaches the police station
safely. There he finds out that Carter was bit
by a Vampire and is turning into them. With no
other way out, Carter suggests Eben kill him.
They both go into a room where Eben cuts his head
off. Only five of them are left but survival looks
possible now. It is the twenty-seventh day. They
have enough food to survive for the next few days
until the Sun rises again. Suddenly, they notice
someone from the house across trying to send them
a signal by flashing lights. Eben assumes someone
is trapped there. He and Stella go to save them.
They are shocked to see Billy there.
It is revealed that with no hope left,
Billy killed his 2 daughters and wife. When he was
about to end his life, his gun stopped working.
After berating Billy for not saving his family,
they cautiously take him to their hideout
but when they reach there, they find
out that everyone else is missing.
Assuming they might have gone to the utility, the
trio head there too. When they are halfway there,
Stella notices a little girl roaming around
the snow. A vampire is about to attack her
from behind. Although Eben tells her to ignore
the little girl, Stella can't stop herself
and rushes to help. The vampire then follows
them. Eben tells Stella and Billy to run away
with the little girl while he distracts
the vampire. All three of them run away in
different directions. Eben Somehow makes it to the
utility but finds Stella and Billy missing.
Billy finally reaches the utility but a vampire
gets in as well. He attacks Billy and bites him
in the neck. After a long struggle, the 2 men
finally kill the vampire by pushing him into the
meat grinder but in the process, Billy’s hand gets
accidentally ripped off too. Eben then notices
that Billy has been bitten so he reluctantly
cuts off his friend’s head with an ax.
It is the last night of the thirtieth day now.
If they can survive this night, they will be
free tomorrow. Other people from the group start
celebrating while Eben sees Marlow and his fellow
vampires gathering through a window. Marlow tells
his fellow vampires that the only reason they
have been able to survive this long is because
they don’t leave evidence of their work behind.
He then orders them to burn the whole town to the
ground. Just when Eben thinks his wife is dead,
she communicates through a walkie
talkie and informs him that she
is hiding under a car in the snow.
Eben promises her that they will watch
the sunrise together. He notices the car
but the vampires have already broken all
the oil pipelines of the town. The oil is slowly
filling up the streets and moving towards the car
Stella and the little girl are hiding under.
Eben realizes there is no way to save her now;
if she runs they will kill her, if she stays she
will burn. The vampires light the fire and slowly,
it starts to take the whole town under it. With no
options left, he takes some of Billy’s blood out
through a syringe and injects it into himself.
He knows that this will turn him into a vampire.
His friends look at him turning into one.
He is now a threat to others in the group
so they decide to kill him. However, his brother
Jake stops them. Eben then says his goodbyes to
his brother and goes out to fight Marlow. After a
long struggle, Eben finally manages to kill Marlow
by jamming his hand through Marlow’s head.
The other vampires see their leader dead and run
away. Finally, the sun rises up and everyone comes
out. Stella and Eben watch the sunrise together.
They share one last kiss. The story ends when the
rays of the sun fall into Eben’s body, he starts
to burn and eventually dies in Stella’s arms.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.